Donald Trump is roasting Ron D santis on
Troth Central
um here's the deal Ron DeSantis at the
beginning of his career would say I'm
Ron D santis I'm Ron DeSantis and I
approve this message and then it morphed
into DeSantis hello this is Governor Ron
DeSantis wishing everyone a Merry
Christmas and then in at least one video
since announcing that he's running for
president he is again pronounced it
DeSantis I'm Ron DeSantis and I'm
running for president to lead our Great
American comeback Trump is now making
fun of it saying he actually thinks
DeSantis sounds better so he's glad that
DeSantis is going with D santis I think
the whole thing is nonsense but I have
to admit like if I'm completely honest
with you
it is a little weird to have multiple
pronunciations of the way you say your
own last name